a gran escala.
Por lo general, se comienza con bocetos.
Yo estaba esbozando este retrato de la artista, de 18 metros, móvil,
listo para la transmisión,
y luego rompí el papel en dos.
Partí la máscara
para tratar de llegar a la humanidad subyacente.
Y una cosa es hacer bocetos, pero por supuesto traducir un boceto
en un edificio de seis plantas que va de gira y debe transportarse
requiere tres meses de trabajo incesante de unos ingenieros excepcionales,
hasta que finalmente llegamos a Miami
e inauguramos el show en abril de 2016.
(Video: Ovación)
(Música: "Formation", Beyoncé)
Beyoncé: Todos Uds., haters, obsesionados con esa bobería illuminati.
Paparazzi, capta mi vuelo y mi confiada frescura.
Soy muy peligrosa cuando llevo puesto mi vestido Givenchy.
Soy tan posesiva que luzco sus collares Roc.
Mi papi es Alabama;
mi mami, Louisiana.
Mezcla ese negro con esa criolla,
y tienes una rara mixtura texana
(Fin de la música)
Denomino a mi obra...
(Ovación)(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Denomino a mi obra "escultura escénica",
pero claro lo que se esculpe en realidad es la experiencia del público,
y como directores y diseñadores,
debemos asumir responsabilidad
por cada minuto que el público pasa con nosotros.
Somos un poco como pilotos
que recorren una ruta aérea para cien mil pasajeros.
Y en el caso del artista canadiense The Weeknd,
tradujimos esta ruta de vuelo literalmente
en un avión de origami de papel plegable
que despegó sobre las cabezas del público,
se destruyó en pleno vuelo, por complicaciones,
para luego resurgir de las cenizas
al final del espectáculo.
Y como en todo vuelo,
la parte más delicada es el despegue, el comienzo,
porque cuando diseñas un concierto de pop,
la materia prima con la que trabajas
es algo que ni un camión, ni un equipo, pueden transportar.
Y no tiene precio,
e inunda cada átomo de aire antes que comience el show.
Es la expectativa del público.
Cada uno trae consigo la historia de cómo llegó hasta allí,
las distancias que viajaron,
los meses que tuvieron que trabajar para pagar las entradas.
A veces pasan la noche fuera del estadio,
y nuestra primera tarea es colmar las expectativas del público,
brindarles un primer contacto memorable con la artista.
Cuando trabajo con hombres,
ellos están felices de ver transformar su música en metáfora...
vuelos espaciales, montañas.
Pero con las mujeres, trabajamos mucho con máscaras y retratos tridimensionales,
porque los fans de la artista femenina
anhelan su rostro.
Y cuando el público llegó a ver el primer concierto en vivo de Adele en cinco años,
se encontraron con esta imagen de sus ojos dormidos.
Si escuchaban atentamente,
oían su aliento dormido haciendo eco por todo el estadio,
esperando a despertar.
Así comenzó el espectáculo.
(Video: Ovación, Aplausos)
(Música)
Adele: Hola.
(Ovación)(Aplausos)
Es Devlin: Con U2, estamos navegando por la audiencia
sobre un terreno que abarca tres décadas de política, poesía y música.
Y durante muchos meses, al reunirnos con la banda y sus equipos creativos,
el boceto recurrente era el siguiente:
esta línea, esta calle,
la calle que une el pasado de la banda con su presente,
la cuerda floja por la que caminan como activistas y artistas,
un paseo por el cine
que permite que la banda se convierta en protagonista
de su propia poesía.
(Música: "Where the Streets Have No Name", de U2)
Bono: Quiero correr
Quiero esconderme
Quiero demoler las paredes
Que me esconden
Es Devlin: El final del espectáculo es como el final de un vuelo.
Es una llegada.
Es una transferencia del escenario al público.
Para la banda británica Take That
finalizamos el espectáculo enviando una figura humana mecánica de 24 metros
hacia el centro de la multitud.
(Música)
Como muchas traducciones de música a mecánica,
esta al principio parecía técnicamente imposible.
Los primeros tres ingenieros consultados dijeron que no,
hasta que al final se logró
manteniendo todo el sistema de control junto
mientras recorría el país,
así que tuvimos que plegarlo en un camión de plataforma
para poder transportarlo sin tener que desmontarlo.
Y, por supuesto, eso significó que la dimensión de la cabeza
estuvo determinada completamente
por el puente de la autopista más bajo que tuvo que recorrer en la gira.
Y debo decirles que resulta que
hay un puente ineludible y fastidiosamente bajo
en las afueras de Hamburgo.
(Risas)
(Música)
Otra de las piezas más complejas técnicamente en las que hemos trabajado
es la ópera "Carmen"
en el Festival de Bregenz en Austria.
Imaginamos las manos de Carmen salir del lago Constanza,
lanzando esta baraja de cartas al aire
dejándolas suspendidas entre el cielo y el mar.
Pero este gesto transitorio, este movimiento de muñecas,
tenía que convertirse en una estructura lo suficientemente fuerte
para soportar dos inviernos austríacos.
Así que hay una gran cantidad de cosas que no se ven en esta fotografía
que implica verdadero trabajo.
Hay gran cantidad de lastre y estructura y soporte en la parte posterior,
y les voy a mostrar las fotos que no están en mi sitio web.
Son fotos de la parte trasera del set,
la parte pensada para que el público no la vea,
por mucho trabajo que implique.
Y este es el verdadero dilema
de un artista que trabaja en la escenografía,
porque gran parte de lo que hago es falso,
es una ilusión.
Y, sin embargo, cada artista trabaja en la búsqueda de comunicar algo verdadero.
Pero siempre nos preguntamos:
"¿Podemos comunicar la verdad mediante cosas falsas?"
Cuando voy a un espectáculo en el que he trabajado,
a menudo descubro que soy la única que no mira el escenario.
Miro algo que me parece igualmente fascinante,
y es el público.
(Ovación)
Quiero decir, ¿dónde más eres testigo de esto?
Tantas personas, conectadas, concentradas,
sin distracciones y sin fragmentación.
Y últimamente, he empezado a hacer obras que se originan aquí,
en la voz colectiva del público.
"Poem Portraits" es un poema colectivo.
Comenzó en Serpentine Gallery en Londres,
donde todos están invitados a donar una palabra a un poema colectivo.
Y en lugar de ese gran retrato de LED
transmitido al fondo del estadio,
en este caso, cada miembro del público
puede llevarse a casa su propio retrato,
y está entretejido con las palabras
con las que han contribuido al poema colectivo.
De modo que conservan un fragmento de una obra colectiva en constante evolución.
Y el próximo año el poema colectivo tendrá forma arquitectónica.
Este es el diseño para el Pabellón del Reino Unido en la Expo Mundial 2020.
El Reino Unido...
En toda mi vida nunca se sintió tan dividido.
Nunca han sido tan atronadoras las voces divergentes.
Nunca ha habido tanta necesidad de encontrar lugares
donde las voces puedan conectarse y converger.
Y espero que esta escultura de madera,
este instrumento de madera, un poco como el violín que solía tocar,
pueda ser un lugar donde la gente pueda jugar y contribuir con su palabra
en un extremo del cono,
salir en el otro extremo del edificio,
y encontrar que su palabra se ha unido a un poema colectivo, a una voz colectiva.
(Música)
Son experimentos simples de aprendizaje automático.
El algoritmo que genera el poema colectivo es bastante simple.
Es como un texto predictivo
entrenado con millones de palabras escritas por poetas en el siglo XIX.
Es una especie de convergencia de inteligencia, pasada y presente,
orgánica e inorgánica.
Y nos inspiramos en las palabras de Stephen Hawking.
Hacia el final de su vida hizo una pregunta bastante simple:
Si como especie alguna vez encontramos otra forma de vida avanzada,
una civilización avanzada,
¿cómo les hablaríamos?
¿Qué lenguaje colectivo hablaríamos como planeta?
El lenguaje de la luz llega a todo público.
A todos nos conmueve. Nadie puede contenerse.
Y en el teatro, comenzamos cada obra en un lugar oscuro, sin luz.
Nos quedamos despiertos toda la noche enfocando las luces, programándolas,
tratando de encontrar nuevas formas de esculpir la luz.
(Música)
Este es un retrato de nuestra práctica.
Siempre buscando nuevas formas de formar y reformar la luz,
siempre buscando palabras para cosas que ya no necesitamos decir.
Y quiero decir que esto,
y todo lo que acabo de mostrar,
ya no existe en forma física.
(Música)
De hecho, la mayor parte de lo que he hecho en los últimos 25 años
ya no existe.
Pero nuestro trabajo perdura en los recuerdos, en las esculturas sinápticas,
en la mente de quienes estuvieron presentes una vez
entre el público.
(Música)
Una vez leí que un poema aprendido de memoria
es algo que queda,
que no se puede perder,
incluso si nuestra casa se incendia y uno pierde todas sus posesiones.
Quiero finalizar con unas líneas que aprendí de memoria hace mucho tiempo.
(Música)
Fueron escritas por el novelista inglés E. M. Forster,
en 1910, pocos años antes de que Europa, mi continente,
(Música)
empezara a desgarrarse.
Y su llamado a la convergencia aún resuena
en la mayor parte de lo que tratamos de hacer ahora.
(Música)
"¡Solo construir el puente! Ese era todo el sermón.
Solo construir un puente entre la prosa y la pasión,
y ambas resurgirán
y el amor humano brillará en su cima.
¡Solo construir el puente! No más vida fragmentaria".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)